Decisive battle for the control machine's cave In just a few tens of seconds from the start of the battle,
the entire force of the Kingdom of Science will be thrown in.
For that, he's absolutely necessary At the
number one cheat power tarpness.
I know your name
Ootama
[music]
[applause]
ana
goo
[music]
Zotter is the mother of the Kingdom of Science
The final battle against the Tsukasa empire is about to
begin
!
Good, good, good,
travel
[music]
According to research by a psychologist at Harvard University, the duration of a human impulse is
only 20 seconds.
It's the first 20
seconds
that will get you out.After that, the enemy will calm down and counterattack.If
you meet, the citizens will surely come.
Minami
me It was
22 seconds
ni
[music]